yeah welcome to this video black against
the repo man it doesn't have a name in
them I seized on for a very long time on
as you seem but I don't know I do know
who that is um okay let's let's go for
some Kings Indian quite at least them
you know beforehand that may be a dumb
need some fishy attacked one okay Bishop
g5 let's go age six and I always played
this set up back in the day when I am
played the Kings Indian on a regular
basis always like this with grouping it
seemed very very elegant to me no f5 hmm
no F is a form of an option maybe maybe
what can play f4 at some point
okay so this is interesting the question
is should I am should I play this kind
of usual Kings Indian stuff with f/4g 5
or is this just too slow he doesn't have
the dark squared bishop and this
actually means that F 3 is quite um
quite a committal move and interesting I
don't think this is a good for white at
all night before I FEI ok c 70 i'm not
sure if i should play a 49 h 52 f force
also very viable option ok let's do this
anyway yeah his plan must be Roxie 195
and something to c7 this is clear but
it's not obvious if he really manages
okay if I go a six now he returns place
a five and I'd be 6 and so on the
typical kind of stuff in this position
but dumb not sure if I go G for now he
takes I can take e four so I was Queen B
6 coming come on let's let's go ahead
here now okay obviously ignore some all
my moves always like that if they play
instantly like you're the biggest idiot
ever maybe I am but it still feels feels
weird that you place everything
instantly okay
of course this some intensive sacrifice
on on age three I don't really care
about 97 or anything here yeah you can
do that doesn't matter okay so 95 right
the look is not important I must I must
second on age three at some point
ok so he don't doesn't want to take the
rook so what now I think I should take
with the bishop
yeah I need to have any group g eight at
some add some some stage so I'm get the
get the kingdom from the g file
there's always Queen em to be 6 Czechia
Queen B 6 check and night h3 this is the
kind of stuff that I'm looking looking
to get get played it's really amazing I
mean I really must is this so ridiculous
what I'm doing that you pre just can
play 95 I don't know it looks it looks
dangerous to me yeah good stuff and now
this I dropped g8 next move I mean how
does it offend this I don't see it at
all threatening am whupped g1 is just G
to check I mean simply the stupid stuff
I'm such an idiot
you
maybe Queen f2 some something but it's
not really really a threat if I would
would be able to double on the G file
but this is really slow now can do that
probably
Kim
yeah this there's not much going on
really it's just blocked now and I don't
really have any any substantial threats
I would need like two or three moves in
a row to it to get get some some threat
going Luke g8 and Queen f2 something
like that in one go would would even win
but it's not obvious how I should manage
that
check
now Queen f2 what's what's happening
this isn't them isn't this winning now I
think this is winning haha this is
really Winningham ok this was I was very
lucky and maybe ok well I'm sorry for
the call the cursing on the way but yeah
he just told me nice yeah this was yeah
this was the absolute last chance I mean
ok let's let's just put it on the board
this is checkmate this was the only idea
that was left in the position and he
gave me gave me those moves this is made
and this is also made so just just
winning but Sam the last trick mean the
really last trick in the position that
was only hoping for this this single
idea that was so left in the position
yeah it was working but of course it was
ridiculous I mean I cannot I cannot take
on age 3 in this in this fashion when he
can play kingi to ya then this is this
this is not working yeah maybe I should
should play the simple move from 90 x e6
i mean i saw that this is possible of
course but i always tempted to play for
all the sacrifices so on I went for for
this stuff this is ridiculous i simply
overlooked kingi to I mean otherwise it
would this was we would just win the
game of course but King g2 is very
simple it's just just a very very
moronic move yeah what what I did what I
saw was that this
doesn't work of course this this is
winning for black and easy to see and if
he takes this is also winning I mean
this here needs to mate and this is what
I calculated but I simply forgot about
King g2 and well in the game he was just
the porn up and I was causing all the
time it was just a piece up of course on
the pony piece up and down and down
again then and then there was this this
is only this one single trick that then
really got got on the board yeah
apologize for the crossing on the way or
the swearing thanks for watching anyway